à partir du moment où la police
c'est-à-dire revendications à faire je
me trouve en face d'un homme qui
m'intéresse parce que moi aussi j'en ai
à faire des revendications justement à
propos de la police et ça c'est un mort
ou un blessé par jour par la police
depuis le 1er janvier non non mais ce
que je veux dire qu'effectivement la
police a pas un rôle facile et moi je
suis pas contre la police en général
hein ce qu'il faudrait c'est qu'il
s'arrange quand même pour qu'à la fin de
l'année il est moins de mort du côté des
assassins du côté de la police
expliquez-moi ce que les policiers
foutent dans le dos des Arabes avec un
revolver à la main et à chaque fois il
tombe racontez-moi pourquoi du manque à
une raison moi je suis d'accord le
problème c'est qu'il y a pas de raison
c'est ça le problème enfin il y en a une
en fait oui c'est que les policiers se
croient extrêmement couvert